52 times a half is 26, and then I have 2w plus 6 on the right side. I don't have
any multiplication here, this is addition. I'm just adding w to its like term.
Subtracting 6 from both sides, we get 20 equals 2w, then we divide both sides by
2, so we're left with 1w is equal to 10. We know the width, but we need to keep
in mind that we still need to find the length. Let's check in with our diagram.
I can replace these w's with 10, so each side is 10 feet. Now, you could have
reasoned your way and figured out the length of l since you know the perimeter
has to add up to 52. Or you could be a little bit more clever. You could just
say the length of the rectangle is 6 more than the width. So, to find the
length, I just have to take the width and add 6, so the length needs to be 16.
And you could, of course, check your answer by finding the perimeter. Add up all
the sides and your perimeter should be 52. Hopefully, you use your equation
skills and got that one right.